Hôm nay, hai người bài thằng sống Thái Lan thông báo ám dụng loạt biển pháp anh đến mới tại khu bực biến giới với căn buc chiê,
nhằm chết phá các mạng nưới lời đảo suyên cuo ra.
Thủ tướng, bay trông thân sinh nè quan trả trở miết,
nếu ngày sẽ hạnh chi qua lại tại bẩy tình biến giới,
dân xuất khẩu một số mặt hàng như nhên liệu,
đồng thời kiểm soát hỏi động tại chính liên quan đến các bằng ngọng tội phạm.
Các biển pháp đường ra trong buổi cạnh căn thằng giữa Thái Lan và căn buc chiê lau thang,
gió trình chấp biển giới và sự cố gió gì định đàn giữa lãnh đạo hay nước.
Các buc chiê sau đó tuyên bố ngừng nhập khẩu sân dầu từ Thái Lan,
phà nước với việc quên đợi thái đống cửa một cửa khẩu.
Thái Lan cũng sẽ sết dù li tánh bà,
tăng kìm chân dân hàn và chương phát cảnh vi dự tiền.
Bởi vì các buc chiê nước này cũng khẳng định,
căn cái chúng tội phạm công nghệ,
bởi vì thành lập ui bán chúng nửa đảo suyên,
gió thủ tướng hôm mạng nế đứng đầu.
Hãy nếu đường những mạnh nếu cộ hợp tác cuối tế trong cuộc chiến trong cây tức tội phạm suyên biển giới.
Chua cùng ngay thủ tướng hôm mạng nế đảy đến thăm lực lượng vũ trang đồng chú tệ tình
về a di hơ,
khu vực giác biển giới với Thái Lan,
ông mặt quên phục đồng viên tinh thành biến sĩ và những mạnh trang kết,
bào đảm hộ cân cho lực lượng tối đồng.